stade hermann panzo de petits bouts en
rivière salée c'est le lieu choisi afin
de réunir les combattants du feu des
îles voisines de chez nous pour les 18
heures de cet échange entre pompiers
intitulé good old games nous nous
retrouvons tous les deux ans afin de
d'échanger nos techniques de comparer
nos matériaux une rencontre sportive
chaleur au rendez vous avec au menu pour
les participants des épreuves plutôt
difficile mais qui au bout permet d'être
opérationnel le moment venu
pour moi c'est une bonne initiative
d'abord et avec les collègues de la
caraïbe épreuve de force de lancer deux
courses et j'en passe 1 to pour la
cinquantaine de pompiers qui a eu
beaucoup de mérite
les échanges restent et demeurent très
importants sont de pures mais de nous
pour jouer dans ce show j'ai plus ou
moins dans l'effort si un bon bagage le
graff est basque et antigua scolaire
nous nuire à sa tion mobile excitant ces
jeux des jeux qui mérite d'être co
disputer et nous permettre de nous
rapprocher la caf caribéenne
atchison a fire tiger a pour mission
depuis l'arrivée du nouveau président de
guyane anglaise de réunir d'ici deux ans
des pompiers venant des autres nations
de la caraïbe était l'objectif pour moi
c'est de continuer à développer à ce jeu
qui la gt feront bien c'est de
développer les créations édifiant
services de pompiers de la carie un
objectif développer l'amitié avant nous
ont malgré la compétition
l'expérience nous a montré qu'il fallait
pas rester
tant sur l'état français donc nous avons
kato un compris qu'il fallait aider nos
chronos le collecte des deee là à côté
ça prouve que cette association des a
bondi de l'accueil à une nécessité
vitale
au final le martiniquais mans michel
manciet meilleur pompiers avec les
autres il sera à la pointe marc et
vendredi pour les rencontres de football